-I want to talk to you about
the Steelers very briefly.
-I mean, already?
That´s all you care about, huh?
-It is. It is.
It´s on my mind.
-It´s like --
what´s wrong with you guys?
-Well, your guy,
Joe Manganiello,
who is a lovely person,
and not just because
he is a big Steelers fan.
But you have sort of
married into that world.
-Yes.
-And you are
such a beautiful woman,
and I believe that if anyone,
if anyone could make
Steelers gear look sexy,
it would be you.
And then I saw this photo
and realized that I was wrong.
[ Laughter ]
You´re not --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I have to be honest with you.
You always look very happy.
You do not seem to have any joy
in your eyes in this photo.
-I mean, it´s like --
The only, like --
I would say
that it´s, like, the --
Only bad thing, like,
that Joe has
is, like, he doesn´t --
It´s like a defect, I think.
It´s like he doesn´t understand
that Steeler clothes is not,
like, a brand, you know?
-Yeah. I see, right.
-It´s like he thinks that that´s
the only thing that is clothes.
Like, if he doesn´t have
a T-shirt or a shirt
or a jacket or socks
that say "Steelers" --
It´s like he doesn´t understand
that that is not clothes.
That´s like --
like a thing for games,
to wear to when you go
to the stadium.
-Yes. Doesn´t understand.
-He doesn´t understand.
-In a perfect world, he would be
on the red carpet at the Oscars,
and they´d say,
"Who are you wearing?"
And he´d say, "The Steelers."
-Yeah, and -- and me too.
And me too.
It´s like --
He, like, sometimes
will lay out things just like,
"Look how beautiful that is."
It´s like --
I´m like, "Yeah, beautiful."
-And I will say, my wife has
made the observation, as well,
that black and gold
are not good colors for a lady.
It is just --
-I mean, that doesn´t really --
I mean,
that´s not the worst part.
That makes you look like
a bumblebee, but --
The worst part is like --
It´s not every day,
for God´s sake, you know?
It´s like every once in a while.
It´s, like, you know.
I could have worse problems
than that.
-You could have worse problems.
Well, I want to bring up
something that might,
to me, maybe is a worse problem.
Because Joe looks like someone
who would be a sports fan.
He looks like an athlete.
-Yes, he is.
-But I did not realize this
until today, that he is still --
still plays
Dungeons & Dragons.
That can´t be true.
-[ Laughs ] Yes.
-He does?!
-Yeah, and he´s like --
He´s obsessed with it.
-Wow.
-He has like a lot of figurines.
He has, like,
a dungeon in the house,
and he has like
a lot of figurines.
-Like a fake dungeon, right?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it was like
a wine cellar and --
It was supposed to
be the "wine cellar,"
and suddenly with, like, the
months, it started to happen.
It´s like -- I wish
I had brought you a picture.
It´s like -- He has, like,
these gigantic heads of dragons
hanging from the wall.
It has, like, a little village
all in the table.
It´s not a wine cellar anymore.
It´s a dungeon.
Just, like, gigantic chairs,
and they love it,
because they feel like it
gets them in the mood, I think.
I don´t know.
-So he actually
has friends over,
and they come
and they go down to the dungeon.
-And they stay there forever.
I just hear them.
I´ve seen very pretty girls
go down there and play, too.
-Oh, wow. And that´s --
You´re very forward-thinking
that you would let that happen.
Now I´m thinking --
-[ Laughs ]
-Now I´m thinking that this
might be all some sort of sham.
[ Laughter ]
"No, honey. They´re just here
for the -- for the dragons."
-Yeah, so, girls play it, too.
But he loves it,
and he invites friends.
And I love it.
I love being part of it
by organizing the room, giving
him food there, beverages.
-And do you bring down, like,
beverages that are
appropriate to dungeons,
or is it just regular beverages?
-I have never really been,
like, in a dungeon dungeon,
so I don´t really know
what´s appropriate.
-Yeah, that´s true.
-I feel like Columbian coffee
is always appropriate,
so I put, like, a thing there
that stays hot
for six hours so I don´t
have to go up and down.
-That´s great.
-And cheese, crackers, um, tea.
-This sounds like
a lovely dungeon.
-Yeah, yeah. I mean --
-I mean, if it´s ever free
for a weekend,
I will Airbnb that dungeon.
-I know. When you´re in L.A.
-Yeah, please.
-When you´re in L.A.,
you´re welcome.
It´s like it happens
all the time in my house.